little shocking snap girls
show's over you can all go home pack
your bags I went for it I really I
really went for it here's Courtney she's
a black widow so what I want to do here
she was called the man-eater and the
mean girl and millions watched as she
got the rose and she got her man Ben
Flajnik but you did not see at all now
I'm gonna make good on my promise I
don't know if he's ever skinny to flip
them all over for that what was the
ocean trip like that was probably the
most fun I had on the show
there skinny-dipping you have a
skinny-dipping yeah it was the first
time we got to talk without the cameras
rolling like you're listening in so I
got some info out of him out there and
you had second in the ocean and then
some yes exactly but just a brief moment
yes just very brief the tide was coming
in it was very was difficult honey um
huh oh wow this is perfect
we saw Robertson make it to the infamous
fantasy suite episode but she tells me
what happened after the cameras left sex
three times in the fantasy suite
I think that I believe that what's in
the blood yeah it's intimately in the
book you say they didn't leave condom
yes exactly I mean they might have been
there rad & Co we're all wondering that
like how do these people protect
themselves I know that's a really good
question I mean I did they just weren't
there I mean maybe yeah them but it
didn't come up so and I didn't think at
the time and I don't know I may be naive
I just assumed he didn't do anything
with anyone else
yep she's got a book I didn't come here
to make friends confessions of a reality
show villain out the 24 so do producers
use booze to help create drama your
season was dubbed as the drunkest to
season yes yes I mean at the end of the
night like a cocktail parties like girls
would be dancing on the bar and they
didn't show any of that stuff but I'm
just a lot of day drinking and I I think
that's another reason I didn't bond with
girls as much was because I'm not a big
day drinker did the producers encourage
you guys to drink I mean it's just there
you know it's what it's in the house
yeah it's just like whatever you want is
there at all times and I also found out
congestus have to answer a 150 questions
survey and take tests I had a bad
feeling about it
cuz it's unnatural it's like you know
SCD
and excited to me I took a blood test
yep I was surprised that on a
questionnaire they asked you are you on
birth control yeah I'm definitely yeah
do they ask you to prove whether you are
or aren't I didn't think I had to prove
that so you answered yes how much did
the producers tell you what to do it's
pretty organic in in a way but there are
looking back there were some situations
I was like I could have chose not to do
that you say you feel like you were
pegged as the villain do you feel like
they set up kind of storylines they know
before you get there they have a you
know they know who's gonna be in just
like I said I have this was so naive
they didn't show any sweet interviews or
like me bonding with the girls
Courtney also dishes about the other men
in her life before The Bachelor
including actor Adrian Grenier APRI
Reese Witherspoon Jim Tom and Jesse
Metcalfe the great guy honestly we were
on and off mostly off and talked about
having sex with him yes there's a little
insecure the first time yeah exactly
which who isn't you know what do you
have to say about Adrian great guy
nothing bad to say about it he said he's
a healthy man yes hello
yeah you're probably gonna get a tectum
Adrian now are you saying thanks hahaha
I will love you forever unfortunately
Benna Courtney's love was not forever
they broke up less than a year after
their 2011 engagement why did you break
up um there was a lot of different
reasons I think to sum it up we we were
just very different I never felt like a
priority there was rumors that he
cheated on you during the engagement is
that true um yes there were pictures
that came out of him another girl with
his hands on her butt and like that was
really hard for me and I never talked
about it until
and don't forget the Kris Jenner
connection she and Ben have been spotted
together often in the last year you're
amazing
including this visit to Ben's home town
of Sonoma last September what did you
think when you saw the photos of him
with Kris Jenner hi I I'm really like
ready for this chapter my life to be
over like I don't know what the
situation was there who knows right yeah
what is your relationship have been like
today up non-existent non-existent
non-existent because of the book we had
a really rough breakup